es aquí en la capilla de san jorge' de
windsor que la reina dará este sábado el
último adiós a quien fuera su marido
durante 73 años el príncipe felipe será
despedido en un servicio fúnebre único
tanto en las circunstancias como en la
ejecución una ceremonia reducida e
íntima como hubiera querido el propio
príncipe solo se prevé la asistencia de
30 personas entre ellas todos los
miembros de la realeza
exceptuando mujeres en embarazo así como
representantes de las fuerzas armadas
con las restricciones por el cob y
todavía en vigor en el país me parece
muy triste hay una cosa que reino unido
hace fantásticamente bien y es toda la
pompa y la ceremonia así que creo que va
a ser muy triste que no vayamos a ver
todo ello por otro lado creo que para la
familia va a ser muy agradable que sea
más personal el ataúd del príncipe será
llevado al servicio en un landrover
modificado que el duque ayudó a diseñar
será cubierto con su bandera personal
que refleja tanto su herencia griega
como sus títulos británicos mientras se
colocará su gorro naval y su espada
encima
y nietos de felipe caminaran detrás del
féretro en su recorrido hasta las
puertas de la capilla antes de que una
salva de cañón y un minuto de silencio
nacional marquen el inicio del servicio
la reina viuda por su parte permanecerá
sentada sola durante todo el funeral
como símbolo del aislamiento al que
muchos se han enfrentado este último año
faces de los creo que habrán lágrimas en
muchos hogares fue que otros nombres
estarán en sus mentes rostros que han
perdido y que no vuelven a ver funerales
a los que no pudieron ir y eso va a
romper muchos corazones una vez que el
ataúd se ha bajado a la bóveda real la
marina hará sonar sus cornetas
finalmente una última bendición del
arzobispo antes de que el himno nacional
concluya la ceremonia